mom this is Michelle  this is your new special friend yep my  girlfriend  we're like over a year now now Derek and  Sarah you'll be staying in your rooms  and Michelle we got y'all set up in the  guest room actually mom I figured  Michelle could just sleep in my room you  know like what we do every night that  for grown-up screamer  I'm 22 you still need your calcium okay  oh thanks for the cookies mom oh that's  all right be back by 11:00 oh you got to  be home before Santa comes down with  Tiffany wait really 11 no  [Music]  baseball cards baseball card I did when  I was 12  see I told you he loved baseball cards  in your office I suppose you could hold  me close like this and kiss me like this  oh I can show me holiday movies for kids  the magic of the classic story as it  comes to life like you've never seen  before  show me Fifty Shades of Grey